President Biden is facing Swift backlash
from environmentalist over his approval
of a massive oil drilling project in
Alaska now it's a major reversal after
he promised no more drilling on federal
lands while on a campaign Trail in 2020.
Ed O'Keefe is traveling with the
president in California and joins us
from Los Angeles Ed good morning what is
this all about
well Nate good to see you this decision
is a complete reversal from The Stance
then candidate Biden took more than
three years ago at a campaign stop in
New Hampshire
no more drilling on federal lands period
period period period
instead the approval of the
multi-billion dollar Willow project will
allow oil giant Conoco Phillips to
operate three drill sites on federal
lands in Alaska's North Slope leases to
drill in the region were approved in the
1990s so the company may use that to
beat back any fights in court the
Interior Department says this plan
blocks conocophillips's initial plan of
also Drilling in two other spots but
that's not stopping criticism from
within the Democratic party Senator Ed
Markey in Massachusetts says the
decision leaves an oil stain on the
administration's climate accomplishments
and the Environmental Group Sierra Club
warned we will suffer the consequences
of this for decades officials say oil
from the project would produce roughly
239 million metric tons of greenhouse
gas over 30 years about the same as
emissions from 1.7 million cars in the
same amount of time the White House also
says it plans to preserve the entire U.S
Arctic and other parts of Alaska from
future drilling all three members of
Alaska's Congressional Delegation are on
board with supporting the willow project
but the decision is reminder that when
it comes to the environment and other
issues like bank bailouts and crime the
president often finds himself at odds
with members of his own party Michelle
alrighty Ed thank you